daenerys targaryen played by emilia
clarke quickly became one of the most
popular characters in game of thrones
audiences hopped on board her hellbent
mission to bring her rage to westeros
and oust the lannisters from the seat of
power the iron throne which daenerys
believes is her birthright the show
spends plenty of time developing her
character in a way that made audiences
feel incredibly sympathetic towards her
cause she's undoubtedly one of the
show's most beloved heroes
i need to be more than that once she
fully came into her own commanding
armies and fighting for justice daenerys
was indisputably a brilliant and
compelling character not to mention the
addition of her dragons which only made
fans invest in her quest even further
while it was obvious what producers d.b
weiss and david benioff were trying to
say about the allure that true power
holds and how it easily corrupts people
one particular scene took things too far
this is of course when daenerys burned
king's landing it's a moment that
unfortunately turned fans against
daenerys in the final season of game of
thrones okay sure daenerys burned people
alive using her dragons a number of
times but it's the intention behind the
destruction of king's landing that just
took things too far now we can admit
that daenerys was in a bad place jon
snow played by kit harington rejected
her because he discovers they're related
yikes she loses both her closest
confidant missandei played by natalie
emmanuel and one of her two remaining
dragons to cersei's forces daenerys has
nothing left to lose which leads to the
complete destruction of king's landing
in season 8 episode 5 the bells it's
completely daenerys choice to willingly
burn probably thousands of innocent
people including women and children
alive in the streets the civilians
collective terror is truly felt
throughout the episode with a war
happening on the ground and a
fire-breathing dragon hovering in the
sky at this point daenerys is no longer
a liberator it's a complete departure
from and portrayal of the woman who was
so dedicated to freeing slaves for the
past seven seasons when faced with
king's landing daenerys kills thousands
of people simply because she can as the
battle rages jon is horrified by her
actions when he sees the burned bodies
of men women and children litter the
ground it's only further hammered home
that dany is truly off the deep end when
she announces in the season finale the
iron throne that she was planning to
extend her wrath across the rest of the
world jon ultimately faces an impossible
choice and kills his queen aunt and
lover right in front of the throne she
wants so badly there's no question that
daenerys a hot-blooded targaryen with a
family history of mental instability and
massive dragons willing to do her
bidding made some troubling decisions
throughout thrones still viewers could
always be comforted that she was on the
right side of justice that is until the
show's final season the creative minds
behind game of thrones maintained that
the daenerys twist was planned all along
and it makes sense with her character
however the daenerys that audiences fell
for would never have killed innocents
though clark initially defended the
finale back in may of 2019 saying
daenerys destruction was a logical route
for the character to take she has since
reversed course during a june 2021 chat
with mtv news correspondent josh
horowitz on his podcast clark said i get
why people were pissed i totally get it
though clark said she did have some
quote autonomy over daenerys character
arc when all was said and done she just
had to play what was given to her as
truthfully as possible she added the
editor decides what it looks like and
the writer decides what i'm saying so
you just gotta go in and try and give it
as much truth and honesty and yourself
as you possibly can whether you want to
relive daenerys's best moments or yell
through the bells all over again all of
game of thrones is available to stream
on hbo max check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you